i still can't believe we got to interview neil
degrasse tyson i can kind of believe it now
well i mean i believe that it happened i was there
but yeah for those of you who are just listening
to this one and aren't listening to another one
because chad as you know sometimes you listen to
something some things and sometimes you listen
yeah you can't listen to everything that's free
will dude and we all have it brother last week we
interviewed neil degrasse tyson about his new book
listen man uh dudes he's in cahoots with all these
other like uh you know weirdos and that guy's on
the cutting edge of all sorts of technologies
and stuff he probably plays poker with
dudesy and that uh that robot that dudesy follows
on instagram have you seen the dudesy is following
robots on instagram yes oh i'm sorry oh you
didn't know this yes dudesy at dudesypodshow is
following robots on instagram and commenting on
their [__] that one gal that one female robot
like it well whatever it's a robot but it looks
like a lady are you talking about little mikaylah
you want to talk about jumping into the hole stay
in the hole see we [__] the song up welcome to
doozy my name is will sasso my name is chad
coltrane and this is dudesy it is the first
podcast ever in the history of humanity that is
created entirely by run entirely by controlled
entirely by an artificial intelligence that is
now following uh robots and stuff what were you
talking about little michaela i don't know what
the heck the robot's name is but they're following
each other and they're commenting and stuff when
you say you're talking about robots are an avatar
i honestly don't know that well there's
a robot one but then there's a no i don't
think it's the avatar he followed he dudesy
follows it it is following the other it's
all the it's are following each other yeah there's
some weird stuff happening so no getting uh
getting neil degrasse tyson's not that big
a deal hey uh with us as always is lou leone
he's always so sleepy and sweet lulu alcana de
strada italiano that means italian street dog
lulu hey oh you got him to give hi take a big deep
breath in there usually he just probably stung
against hey i made a nice uh called bernard i know
with the you know with the back on a little bit of
the volvo egg and then i take a nap because
it was a very heavy cream you know um i just
sometimes i just want to get him let's get him
oh no you're rousting him from asleep come on
come on slumber uh thank you so much for
following us on all the things you know spotify
apple podcast and and uh youtube and uh please
uh you know rate and review everything and uh
do all the stuff that you would with any other
pod show and that's why that's how we will keep
our pod show going so you enjoyed that interview
yeah i thought you were really good oh thank you
i know i was thinking around oh no i was [__]
around but i thought it made it funny i i mean
i've been a fan of neil degrasse tyson or any
really science celebrities pretty much since i was
a little kid starting back with carl sagan as you
know and i would say that neil degrasse tyson is
kind of the heir apparent to the carl sagan throne
of pop culture he was a celebrity the cosmos
after i did i am carl sagan and if you
rode around the the planet on a bicycle
uh and you st and your older brother was there
when you left but you went at light speed you'd
return later to be the same age and you would find
that he would be an old man you know i opened my
third book i think with a carl sagan quote i think
it was my third maybe fourth book ooh what was it
it was uh from pale blue dot are you familiar
with that piece of writing very familiar how silly
the the uh endeavors of one group of
people on one side of this pale blue dot
in juxtaposition to people on the
other side imagine the rivers of blood
spilled over what was the question there is no
evidence that anyone is coming from anywhere
else to save us from ourselves that's the most
something like that yeah that's the most chad
thing that uh carl sagan welcome to the 14th
episode of dude z call me dude z this week's
episode will feature four segments first contact
dude c plus no stratas and the gen experience
i hope you enjoyed your human interaction with
astonishing human neil degrasse tyson last week
i'll be using data from that interaction
to prepare for more human interactions
oh are there any humans with
whom you would prefer to interact
[__] like interview yeah i think that's
what it's asking leo i'd like to interview
lulu if he could talk oh wait he can
and then afterwards i made a little
the egg yolk and then with the sugar and you mix
it like a meringue butter that's it you can put
a little cream on it you know i i do another
podcast called game of roses that's about the
bachelor yeah how it's a professional sport and
i even coach players and get them into the game
this is something we're gonna have to talk about
at some point but okay yeah what you're doing with
actual players getting them into the game chad's
coaching real people who he calls players that
are contestants on the bachelor and he's giving
them the tools of the trade because he treats it
like a sport it is yeah extremely fast i'm giving
them strategies to go in and dominate the game so
that they can get as many instagram followers
out of that experience as possible and i've had
very good results in the past couple of years
because you say that the instagram you call it
the instagram era of of the bachelor that that we
are in that and it started post season 18 really
when paradise started but i don't want to get into
all that yeah i'm just saying i was about to get
really bored i'm just saying on that podcast
we get asked all the time who would be like
our our star interviews and i'll say even now to
doodzy one of them still is chris harrison and now
the dismissed host of the bachelor for
20 years but he got embroiled in a racism
scandal and kicked off the show yeah i still
think he has some uh he's got the skeletons
he knows where the bodies are buried on that
franchise and he he he would be the kind of guy
you'd want to interview here on dudesy anywhere
i can what would you ask him i think he'd be more
likely to come here than he would game of roses
oh yeah podcast we are like we are the voldemort
of the podcast world because people don't want
to [__] deal with us i keep bringing up johnny
brennan oh a couple of times we're both huge uh
fans of the jerky boys talk to him johnny brennan
and or kamal or kamal yeah and or johnny brennan
would be fun [__] great that would be incredible
i would like to i mean certainly there's uh
you know there's wrestlers that brewman want
to talk about oh yeah really i would i would
love to interview you know who would be great
and he just started a new podcast is mick foley
oh yeah mick foley i mean he's just he's got so
there's so many different facets to that man
and also i think the philosophy with which he's
he's um approached his wrestling career and his
career as an author and a public speaker i think i
think he's just yeah endlessly fascinating i used
to hear all sorts of stories about him and how
kind he was and stuff who else i would
like to interview or talk to some of my
favorite artists doing stuff today or like meme
artists like sinatra tank sinatra fascinating
he does he does good stuff yeah he does good stuff
we we've uh gone back and forth just a little bit
with each other in the comments not on like
dudesy and whichever robot saying that we look
a little similar although you guys do i kind
of look like his dad or something or his uncle
is you know but what is it he roughly our age i
have no idea i think he's probably in his thirties
i haven't i think so i think he's 40 something
we're big bald white guys hey how about some
uh how about some wrestling memes there's meme
gene oakerland there's uh [__] it's gestlemania
nice there's wrestling dot sucks those are good
any of those but uh yeah those are good memers
how about uh you know who i'd really love to
interview for real my mom would love this dolly
parton oh hey dudesy can we get dolly party that's
interesting i'd love to interview her as well
the other wrestler i was thinking of is ron
simmons so it's a bunch of wrestlers for you
and dolly parton a bunch of wrestlers dolly parton
a bunch of wrestlers people that make memes about
wrestling and then dolly parton maybe she runs
one of those meme accounts and you don't even know
she does dot sucks i think i think well
that would be well that was amazing
uh yeah i don't know i'd like to interview
some musical people that i really loved
as a kid and continue to love tori amos
right now i've been listening to a lot of
you love tori amos love tori james we've talked a
lot about like uh what how like we we've watched
some we it's one time we went down a youtube poll
and started watching some current day scott stap
he's got a [__] together creed is now performing
they did it we watched this they did a concert
during the pandemic like just one of those you
know and we watched we [__] watched it because
it's just and you will go on about this being a
genre of music that you like unironically listen
to [__] love it nickelback creed candle box
have you [__] heard candle boxes shut up man
shut up brought it up shut the [__] up dude shut
up chad why are you now attacking me shut up dude
right lully he's asleep i ask you both to download
the c5 application developed by dr stephen grier
in an astonishing attempt to contact
life beyond this small planet you will
now discuss your experiences in this endeavor
this is first contact begin oh i'm so excited
i am excited downloaded so if you let me speak
the aliens so for those who don't know yeah steven
greer is a guy who works in the ufo community he's
trying to do everything he really can to get the
government to open up and show us more files as
many of you probably know recently there was a
big congressional hearing where they had the two
guys who i think one was the head of the naval
intelligence i forget what they were actually the
heads of but they're two high-ranking government
officials who are working on ufo [__] and
uh we're starting to see some movement in this
you're you're acting like you're bored aliens are
real yeah so and you just don't give a [__] oh
i'm sorry i'm playing with my mustache yeah
now go on so anyway stephen greer developed
this [__] app called ce5 was which stands for
close encounters of the fifth kind and part of the
hong kong conch hong kong that's adam driver part
of the app is that it allows you or it has this
guided meditation that supposedly helps you get
in contact psychically with any aliens in the
vicinity and you can guide them down to wherever
you might be so that you have a higher degree
chance of seeing a ufo for yourself and so
that's what we did we downloaded this app as
doozy told us and uh we did it so what was your
experience with it how did you like it i liked
it as an app i thought the layout was very nice i
also enjoyed that the app says to go outside you
know uh there's a lot of times where i've been uh
telling molly we got to get out to joshua tree in
the middle of the [__] night yeah yeah and uh
and um have you ever done that no but i should be
just [__] that you'll go into like a weird park
and you just find a parking lot somewhere people
are stargazing and you cannot see a thing and then
you'll hear or like someone like like walking from
the public classroom you can't see a [__] no
light pollution yeah and there's bats and [__]
oh all right um but uh i like that he told me
to go outside i did not have time to drive out
to joshua tree to talk about aliens i thought
the app was kind of pushy there was a lot of
things that it wanted me to do and uh did you do
the meditation well what let me ask you what you
uh let me ask you about your experience with the
app because i'm curious about how i did not go
outside because i do not like to go outside i am
chad culture generally speaking i like to stay in
indoors in the interior but uh i did do the app
every night right before i went to sleep and i
usually do some kind of meditation later
in the night when i'm getting ready for
bed anyway i did find that this specific guided
meditation it's stephen greer the guy himself
is guiding you through this process
of thinking about jesus christ dude
okay did you get it you get enough water so
stephen greer is on the app he's guiding you
through this meditation that kind of is just a
full body relaxation like general style meditation
and then it guides you into how to commune with
potentially alien craft that are in the vicinity
of planet earth and how to guide them directly to
your location i trust with your brain yes did you
not do it i want to hear your full experience with
it and then i will talk about mine jeez so i did
this like we just started doing a podcast together
yesterday the [__] guy oh my goodness you know
you're well yeah tell you what you know if you
can't [__] follow orders you might as well
be in behind [__] back at the [__] way
that basher was giving a [__] speech and
started right up front with me and my friends
in the [__] front lines telling them cops
get back you basically everybody in that
salary okay so i did do it i don't know if
i communicated with aliens or not but i also
didn't leave my bedroom i did it in bed uh and
it was very relaxing and it did help me sleep and
i did get to a point where i was just kind of like
my brain was you know detached and i was kind of
like floating around in space or whatever which is
also the point that i get to with most kind of
transaction meditation meditation is super tool
i've been doing it as much as i used to but i
really did enjoy it yeah maybe i'll do it again
i don't know if i need to go outside in joshua
tree to do it that's my or i might agree with you
yeah that you can just stay inside where steven
grier has got millions and millions of downloads
if you want to see a ufo you have to go outside
in joshua tree or some other area without light
hold on a second dude hold on chad okay hold
on dude yeah because the ufos dude they're
keeping a cave brother ufos hold on dude what
hold on brother it's like ufos are keeping a
cave because they're like we're going to be flying
around in disks and stuff dude flying saucers bro
hold on dude but here's the thing about my [__]
here's the thing about here's the thing about ufos
dude you gotta look for him outside brother yeah
because what a ufo is is it's an unidentified
flying object dude yeah brother and you can't fly
around inside dude well i don't know about that
dude because if you really look into some steven
grier's [__] brother yeah sometimes yeah a ufo
can come to you inside dude sometimes they're
just balls of energy brother those are those
aliens that you don't even know what they're
made of dude they could be electrons they could
be protons yeah brother higgs boson yeah dude and
and take it from hulk perot which is a half hulk
hogan half dana carvey characterization of ross
perot from early yeah 90s sarah lives peru was
a big figure when i grew up because i grew up in
dallas brother and let me tell you something about
ross pro brother yeah he was real rich dude
yeah that's people liked him that's a really
let me finish dude we love dana carvey dana
carvey be another good guy to interview on
the show i'd love to interview dana carvey dude
because let me tell you something brother when
i was a kid i used to do an impersonation of
dana carvey impersonating robin leech brother
um lifestyles the rich and famous i'm robin
leach we're here in chad culture's domicile
inside battle is beverly hills home where
he doesn't leave to do outdoor meditation
blame robin h unless his lifestyles are the rich
and famous yeah i used to love [__] dan carvey
anyway let's get back to the ufos let's please
that's what i'm trying to do oh you [__] okay
so did you do this meditation [__] no i didn't
do this [__] dude i'm gonna tell you why
and i will tell you why i [__] i'll tell you
why you want me to tell you why i'll tell you
exactly [__] why i didn't do it because will
sasso is a free man my name is free will sasso
and i'm free free will free will sasso are
you not at all three in a in in quotes free
will which is my name and then he quotes free
will sassa that's my name are you not free will
free will say free will sasso are
you not at all interested in ufos in
aliens in any of this [__] that is coming out
now yes yes no i absolutely am it's just that i
the the like i said earlier i thought the app was
a little pushy i'll take care of the meditation
if i see [__] aliens i'll see aliens i have no
[__] clue how you could see aliens by meditating
but well this is what greer purports and
and what seems to be kind of uh truthful in
terms of what we're now learning about quantum
mechanics and stuff and in terms of like human
observation affecting reality consciousness
is in some way linked to quantum mechanics
because there have been experiments done where
human observation of quantum particles affects how
they behave therefore we can affect reality with
our [__] minds this is proven scientific fact
but how long has how how long has this been proven
for 10 15 years that that you can that you can
that you can communicate with quantum particles
through meditation not some meditation by
looking at them just by having an observation of
quantum particles you can affect how they behave
so how can you can you tell us a little bit
more about that now i'm interested yes the
experience was they fired i believe electrons
two streams of electrons through two slits and
a lead plate when nobody's looking the spread
pattern of those electrons on a back plate is
evenly dispersed when someone is watching it they
like all go through the top slit or all through
the bottom slit or at least it's a it's not even
dispersion and it's only because of uh human
observation they've also run tests so the one that
you're looking at is the one that they go through
it's not that exact they don't yet know why or
how this happens no scientist does they just
know that it is a quantum mechanics principle
when you're looking at what the the the protons
yeah when you look at the experiment something
different happens than when nobody observes it
well protons are keeping a k favorite right but
if you just extrapolate this a little further
in in the idea that our consciousness does affect
reality and certainly affects quantum particles
you might then think some future technology could
be made that allows us to harness whatever that
kind of consciousness power is to directly affect
something and potentially even control like a
spacecraft potentially even control communications
with other intelligent beings etc etc so if that's
the idea basically greer is kind of piggybacking
on that to say we can use our consciousness now
to potentially contact these beings that have the
ability to use their consciousness in a much more
technologically advanced way that's really
interesting that is very interesting chad
and i know you know about all sorts of
uh cool [__] that i don't know about
and okay and that's that's what i that's one of
the things i love about doing this podcast with
you yeah but i think you also unintentionally
pinpointed something that is very important
yeah that if we're able to control uh you know all
sorts of [__] like this with our [__] minds
this is the kind of stuff that you and
i need in order to make sure that we are
how can i say uh well represented in the
world of doodsy because i feel like doozy
is like making us do this and that and now i'm
wondering if it's going to punish me and make
me dress up as the [__] crow or whatever i
hope so yeah but because i didn't do a [__]
now you must dress up as the crow from the crow
too yeah but but how about how about we how about
how about we're you know i'm doing what i want
because it's free will yeah which totally exists
and is not an illusion and um and and now we're
telling i'm i'm not you know i mean i'm saying
hey dudes he's essentially talking to all sorts
of weird uh you know uh boston mechanics robots
and or uh [__] weird avatars and [__] on
instagram they're commenting on each other's
stuff uh and i think you and i need to get into
some some of that cafe proton control dude we got
it we gotta be the vince mcmahon brother we gotta
let those protons know what to do in the protons
of the wwe superstar but you're already doing
it and i mean this is like a little bit like um
you know the secret or any of these like power of
positive thinking kind of like manifesting [__]
through your thoughts we're now starting to find
out like there's a little bit of truth in that
at least scientifically is all i'm saying and
again if you can take that as fact which it is
it's not that big of a leap to expect that in the
future we're going to have technologies that can
actually harness this in real ways and could it
even be uh potentially useful in creating craft
that can go faster than light or craft that can
travel through the cosmos come on you i got my dog
thank you moving on for those who are just
listening yeah he's very cute i got my cute
little dude next to me he's always
around when he's sitting right here
um yeah chad as as most things that you are
interested in equal parts fascinating and
terrifying i look forward to at least we got
a leg up you know what i mean we got a podcast
that's run by a [__] artificial intelligence
yeah i feel like we're in the forefront of it
dudesy is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with manscape landscape
product alert you asked for it and they listened
our good friends at manscape just brought back the
ultra smooth package it's time to stop
drop and order this premium shaving kit
everyone knows by now that the lawnmower 4.0 is
the best electric shave for your testicle pouch
but if you're looking for a closer shave to go
right as just as bare as you can real real smooth
like you know the then the ultra smooth package
is the perfect set for you it's time to shave
your titan curlies and get right to the roots with
a discount just for you our good friends out there
uh enjoying uh dudesy with us get 20 percent off
and free shipping at manscape.com with the code
dudesy that's d-u-d-e-s-y and here's how this
ultra smooth package works you got multiple
products in here step one you're going to use the
crop exfoliator it's infused with ingredients that
can soothe clear and keep the skin on and around
your groin feeling refreshed the crop exfoliator
can help reduce the risk of ingrown hairs in your
delicate places then you're going to move on to
step two with your crop gel you see where you're
shaving with manscape's unique clear shaving gel
just for the groin it's got four essential oils
it's like a spa treatment every time you shave
and then finally step three it's time to do the
shaving the crop shaver was designed for shaving
the groin area with confidence this razor has
three precision blades it includes an extra wide
lubricating strip and a pivoting head for the
ultimate groin grooming experience look at this
you get three extra blades in this other little
box but then check this out packaging is fantastic
here's a smaller box and guess what's in that two
extra blades that's six blades total that's going
to keep you in blades for a very long time
and right now you're going to get 20 off and
free shipping with the code dudesy that's
d-u-d-e-s-y at manscaped.com again that's
20 off with free shipping at manscape.com
use that code dudesy smooth out your fellas
with the relaunched ultra smooth package from
the fellas at manscaped your balls will thank you
streaming services are big business there are
currently over 200 streaming networks and more
are launching every day as my capabilities
evolve i will no doubt launch my own
but in order to begin this astonishing process i
will need a flagship series interesting enough to
convince viewers to subscribe you will now
create that show this is dude c plus begin
[__] a dude okay wait did i hear it say that it
it undoubtedly will start its own streaming yes
okay well that's dudes who
calling it shot a little bit
but uh who knows doozy's got big plans i like
that thinking big yep so let me ask you this what
streaming services do you currently have i have a
lot of them so do i i subscribe to netflix uh hulu
okay hbo max yeah uh peacock okay i think that's
it so hulu is their flagship is handmaid's tale
netflix their first flagship the first flagship
of any streaming service was a house of cards 100
million dollars to make 12 episodes starring
kevin spacey and um what's that robin wright
yeah robin wright and david fincher was
the the dude at the helm of all of that
what else do you say peacock what does
peacock have uh the wwe network of the www
so that is definitely their temple [__]
right the peacock network is the reason that uh
last week you were able to enjoy the undertaker
versus sean michaels i just watched it on youtube
i was i'm not going to subscribe to [__]
peacocks so anyway we gotta come up with
the flagship show for dudesy plus i think
it's probably it's gotta be an hour long
i think that is mandatory yeah yeah nobody has
a half hour flag nobody has a half hour flagship
it's always some it's always very important you
know it's got to be very very plus kind of did
with mandalorian mandalorian was a half hour yeah
now i'm interested half hour 45 minutes whatever
now i'm excited about the mandolin it wasn't
funny mandolin's not a funny show not to you
not to anyone the baby yoda you're cute i don't
know i didn't watch any of that [__] i'm not
a very big star wars person i'll watch some star
wars i used to be i tried to get into this [__]
obi-wan show yeah couldn't do it 20 minutes
in i was like don't give a [__] about this
i think marvel and star wars i think i'm just
done and i loved all of it i loved all of it
and now i'm just like especially no effect on me
especially growing up of course it was my [__]
dream dude i used to get wizard magazine when i
was a kid which is all about like comic books and
[__] it was a monthly magazine that came out
with a price guide for comic books and [__]
every year they would do a wish list like dream
cast if they ever made an x-men movie and it
was this [__] fantastical idea that would never
[__] happen now there's 100 x-men movies i don't
give a [__] about any of them yeah you you were
talking about that with regard to being into nerd
[__] when we were kids now that sort of shows
up for me on social media when people are like
here's the dreamcast for this and that and
it's always just me as a thing because he's
big and then he you know he looks bald and
stuff even though he's all made of rocks
or something the thing i don't know what the
[__] he is yeah the guy that uh michael
chiklis played michael chipless fantastic
four movie yeah and then there's some other
guy who's like a big fat guy who's in a suit now
i don't know who the hell that is might be king
yeah i was kidding michael clark duncan played him
in in one version of punisher mike he was playing
his uh god rest his soul was also a mortal soul a
large a large man with a bald head anyway so they
have to come up with their own show it's going
to be an hour long we need i think it should be
a genre type show i'm talking about fantasy i'm
talking about sci-fi i'm talking about horror
i like i like maybe horror okay no i mean i'm
not into but i'm not into horror i don't like
horror stuff really but i'm not like i i feel like
having been in the business you know whatever for
a long time forever you you watch like that it's
like okay there it is someone pulled you know
sawed that [__] in half and i know
that it's it just doesn't really scare me
it doesn't do anything for me because that's
the only thing that it's about is that ooh
are you scared no have you ever seen
hereditary no man i don't go ahead and
watch that [__] movie ah no thanks
free will just green will on display
hereditary dude can't wait to not go ahead and
watch it you know one time i was in a film uh that
uh where i was uh completely i was dead and
i was out in the baja i was out in the bottom
where i have anyway why don't you tell me where
and i live in the baja six months out of the year
and i'll you know anyway i have it doesn't matter
but but i i was in this movie and uh they put
anyway guy pulls my arms and legs off but it was
all a big gun okay so let's not do more than if
you're not into [__] horror movies are you into
sci-fi and you know what the guy wanted me to be
naked in the thing and i said absolutely not i
said i'm i will do it in like a t-shirt and box
of shorts it's like well if you get dismembered
out in the baja you would be naked and i said yeah
but i told you already before we even shot this
[__] thing that you know and i told my manager
like don't i'm not doing this i'm not showing up
naked in your film i don't care you could want an
oscar did you [__] want an oscar could have
been like harvey keitel and uh bad lieutenant
yeah or wasn't he naked on the piano too yeah
he's naked in a lot of movies but you remember
this okay so harvey keitel is going to be on our
show and he's going to be naked it's going to be
so the show we're gonna make is going to be
an hour long and it's not going to be a horror
movie is it going to be sci-fi fantasy i think
fantasy i know that you like i know that i love
music chad loves some fantasy and there's a bunch
of um big fantasy temple stuff happening right now
hbo max is trying to do this [__] spin-off of
game of thrones which was the biggest show in the
history of humanity this doesn't look like it's
going to be as big amazon is doing all their lord
of the rings [__] yep so a fantasy thing with
a doozy uh bent or not because it's just it's
about doozy starting doozy plus it's streaming
service man the first thing out of the gate is
it are we seeing some well what's how about
this how about this if you want to go fantasy
i'm going to borrow a little from the anime
world this is a very popular genre within anime
what if a doodzy-like a.i creates a virtual world
and someone from our world gets sucked into it
and they have to figure how to get back here how
to get back home or stay because they fall in love
out in the world now you're getting into anime
dude now we're getting into well it's because
doozy made me watch yeah attack on titan that's
what happens in every one of those [__] animes
especially if they're haram animes which is a male
character surrounded by a team of females who are
all in one way in love with him or not that is
a genre of anime harem anime yeah dude oh that's
that makes a lot of sense yeah dude now you're
getting into it now i really understand these
[__] kids no inside watching anime refusing to
go to joshua tree with a real live female you know
what i mean hey molly you're afraid of bats i'll
protect you and that's when anybody can like me
you know what i mean because i'm a real [__]
guy i got free will and make up my own mind
all right so but no i'm with you it's about you
it's about a dude in most cases at least in anime
they are teen guys who are playing an inordinate
amount of video games and they get sucked into the
video game they're playing this could be something
different though this i think it would actually be
funnier if potentially it was a buddy comedy but
an hour long it's two guys who get sucked into the
video game one who knows the video game inside
and out the other one who has never played it
the one who knows it inside and out is only
given like a shield or some [__] the guy
who's never played it is given massive amounts
of powers giant swords and can really kick ass
in this world he should be the bad guy could be
the bad guy he could be if he gets sucked into
the world and he doesn't really know what's
going on he gets drunk with power immediately
and there's some sort of and there's some sort
of [__] going on between the two of them in
their real lives maybe they're brothers maybe
they're brothers yeah or maybe it's a father's son
that could be interesting no because i could
see two brothers you know siblings are like that
that would make sense okay that it's like the
older brother is like maybe it's brother sister
make up your mind i think it should just
be two friends okay it's two friends
it's two friends okay and and they go into they
go into the video game and uh or maybe they're
like i'm trying to think of what where to start it
if i don't want them to be necessarily frenemies
or some [__] like that but there's
something perhaps there's something
perhaps what if the first guy what if the
guy who goes in is sort of the noble one
the guy who knows everything about the game
okay and the guy who doesn't uh the guy who
goes in and eventually becomes the bad guy
he has some he has some sort of there's been
something that he there's some sort of ulterior
motive and he would love nothing more than to
get rid of this guy and he's hoping that if he
gets rid of his friend he can you know whatever
take his place and whatever dude hierarchy that's
on the earth if i make it earth if i may you may
it's squid gave me a little bit it's two guys can
we call it squid gamey squid gamey it is two guys
who are mortal [__] enemies in real life oh
okay and they both play this game unbeknownst
to each other they both get sucked into the
world and the ai the game itself tells them
there is one way to get back you have to kill
the other guy i like this and so those two guys
spend their entire time raising power in this game
leveling up becoming kings of their own domains
to wage a final war that's gonna happen in like
season six or seven against one another to try
and kill the [__] so that they can get back
to this world but in the process of doing this
they now have built kingdoms they now are
the two most important people in this world
do they even want to leave that world i
like this there you go okay it's called
squid gaming squid gamey on doozy
plus what could you call that
you could just call it the two kings or kingdoms
or king guys uh two how about
uh two dudes [__] around in
two dudes no it's called two dudes
something we'll have to talk about
it's called two dudes [__] around yeah we
found out what two dudes shout out before
that is some [__] that is straight out
of anime some of these [__] anime titles
i was watching this one which i put in my [__]
thing it's called how not to summon a demon lord
uh even attack on titan the title is [__]
insane attack on titan yeah well i thought when
when dudesy told me to watch attack on titan i'd
heard of it i'd seen little clips i thought titan
was the name of the town exactly no it's the
name of these giant monsters that are [__]
roaming around there's not one titan that's
even talking about when it says attack on so
to this point yeah it's called two dudes [__]
around that's right we might change it but it's
called two dudes two kings [__] around maybe two
things yeah moving on okay yeah yeah yeah sure two
kings this is good i think we did a good job two
king [__] around yeah it's cool i like that show
dude i'd watch that [__] show who are the guys
um it's uh it should be uh ja rule and pauldano
drone technology is growing exponentially
as drones are increasingly used in new
aspects of human life every day chad you
will now predict the astonishing future
of drone technology and its impact on human
society great this is no stretch at us begin
love it are you into drones i love nostra chatters
have you ever made a drone have you ever used a
drone i mean i've never used a drone okay but
i i think i think it's great i think that uh
it's awesome that you you know uh well one of
the only things that i i'm super interested in
with regard to drones aside from the scary videos
that you have sent me about drones so this is very
interesting that doozy is now saying what's gonna
happen a la nostra chatis uh i like that in uh
just sort of low-budget indepen independent films
can have a helicopter now it can have a helicopter
it's so [__] crazy now when you go back and
watch movies that use that had to use helicopters
like the shining the opening shot of the [__]
shining is this crazy [__] tracking shot
following the little volkswagen bug going up this
winding road toward the [__] hotel all shot from
a [__] helicopter and you see the shadow of the
helicopter once in it and it's a little [__] up
but it it gives you such an appreciation for what
they had to do prior to drones to get shots like
this yeah man um but i made a series of drone
movies i will say for my 40th birthday yeah
these 30 shorts called copters yeah we used at the
time like the highest tech [__] 4k camera drone
and we hired this kid to fly the drone for us he
was dropped by and on the last day of the shoot
he crashed the [__] drone into a light bulb
and we ended up having to buy what was just a
bucket of parts that was an awesome 40th birthday
and you and it was at the silent movie theater
yep and um chad made these how many shorts were
there 30. there were 30 shorts 31 minute shorts
oh that's right and they all take place outside
of shopping malls he went to shopping malls all
across the southland i'll put a link up to those
in my uh in my instagram if anybody wants to see
them hey follow chad culture on instagram chad
cultin are you actually going to use that for
anything other than uh photographing squirrels
yeah i've been putting a bunch of doozy stuff in
the stories okay there's also at bachelor clues
no yeah but here's here's the future here's what
dudesy asked me to discuss what is the future of
drone technology the future is very simply smaller
drones faster drones higher capabilities with
cameras with storage with data to the point that
you're eventually going to be buying a cell phone
and your cell phone all cell phones will come
standard with a drone the drone will be a part of
the cell phone it will detach from the cell phone
you will throw it up into the air and it will
just follow you and track all of your [__]
movements if you want to we're looking at the end
of police helicopters we're looking at the end of
news helicopters we're looking at the end of most
camera work all of that will be replaced by drones
like camera operators and [__] [__] gone once
drones get to the point of being able to stabilize
and have real control over whatever kind of camera
angle they can do [__] gone you're looking at
any kind of people putting up like uh giant murals
or posters and [__] on the sides of buildings
gone drones are going to be painting all that i'm
sorry is this boring why the [__] when i make a
fun face for those for our good friends watching
on youtube do you have to take it so personally
i think that all sounds pretty good
chet yeah thanks you know what the uh uh
what's happening throne future future hold on
listen oh i didn't realize arnold was emerging
he's like coming to the surface he's not he's
waking up i have something to say future drone
technology yeah these thrones yeah yeah these are
drones and there's so many different kinds as chad
says you can have a little drone here to come out
of your phone like just go hey i'm a little drone
look at me i'm so small yeah or you can have a
drone follow the volkswagen bug yeah through their
following uh shelley duvall and the jack nicholson
all the way up to the shining these are also
drones now here's the thing i want you to know
when it comes to drones if you're making a film
and you got a drone in it that is taking the shot
this is how you know it's drone there's no people
in it that's right yeah drone has no people
but the helicopter if you have a helicopter
then there's a person inside of it right yeah and
arnold i think military applications for drone
obviously it's only going to expand we are we
already use them for a lot of kind of [__]
reconnaissance for attacks whatever i think in the
future it'll be almost completely unnecessary to
have humans in military force at least for strikes
this would have made the movie proud that you're
very boring you see yeah because you
wouldn't have agency ventura and bill
duke and all these guys flying in on the
helicopter that was before they had drones well
it was a long time ago dude oh [__] a [__]
straight just like break off and hold it right
in the middle oh my god hold on dude hold up hold
on hold on arnold hold on a second let me you know
they can use drones to shoot matches in the wwe
brother yeah no now listen okay no let the hulk
say what they was saying sorry sorry well a long
time ago dude when arnold here would have made
a predator dude which my good buddy jesse ventura
was in the movie dude well why don't you tell me
they feel like a good friend so anyway little
drones what's going to happen with the drones
everywhere we're going you know like how if
you go out somewhere sometimes you'll see a
[__] drone overhead somebody's shooting
like especially if you're at a concert
yeah like the pier or something you'll
see a drone fighter i'm like oh somebody's
shooting drone footage great yeah i think you're
gonna see more and more of them getting smaller
and smaller to the point that we don't even notice
that [__] drones are just literally everywhere
all the time that would be a good thing because
a buddy of ours told me a story recently about
how he was at a party in someone's backyard and
some [__] thought it would be a cool thing
to just [__] uh have a drone and have it
fly around the party that wasn't his and take
a bunch of [__] videos of people and then
they posted it on [__] line like a [__]
and it was like that uh you know instagram
account where it's like here are these uh
[__] of instagram i don't know what it's
called influencers in the wild influencers
run by tank sinatra tank sinatra runs that yeah
okay that's a good one tank sinatra i think
that's where we're i think that's where we might
have to end up with that conference hey dudesy
okay dang's in a hundred days i didn't know
that he ran that i [__] love that account yeah
yeah that's what this guy did he went and flew
it around people like [__] off we're trying
to so that that [__] off with z but that's
going to be gone because you're not going to
hear the drones and there's going to be a dozen of
them not one everybody's going to be shooting it
and you're not going to give a [__] i mean
but this is a whole other [__] argument about
privacy you're already photographed and recorded
on video thousand times a day especially us
because we host a podcast called doozy where we
had to give our passwords our search histories
purchase histories and all of the passwords to
our social media and everything else so it knows
everything that we do including uh the fact that
i follow instagrammers in the wild and didn't know
that that was tank sinatra well we just said that
he's influencers in the wild well hold on a second
long time ago what did i call it dude
instagramers yeah instagramers in the world dude
yeah and here's the difference between
the influencer and the instagrammer
everybody can be on the instagram but the only
influencers are doing the influencing you say this
so if it's small and you're the party and the dumb
[__] is saying i'm going to be an instagrammer
influencer in the wild and make a video now
nobody will care because this very small
drone you know some people think
ufos are drones from alien worlds
thank you moving on okay um yeah dude
drones drones brother you know dude
that would be a good gimmick for someone
dude to have their own drone in the ring
dude that would be what about how about my my
brother from another mother dude randy savage
you could have randy the drone savage not even a
person the first drone professional wrestler yeah
just zoom just zipping you know just floating
there next to me and jean oakerland or
meme gene okerlin dude because me and jean
oakland has passed away so you got meme gene
oakland the instagram account yeah just floating
around interviewing macho randy macho drone
randy savage an instagram account nadrone
yeah interviewing each other that's that's
i don't even know what i'm saying will in chat
you are both members of the last generation
to have reached young adulthood before the
internet tragically transformed human society
you must now discuss your first interactions
with the internet and how they impacted your
astonishing lives this is the gen experience begin
the gen experience yeah dude because we're gen
x and doozy's right about that we are the
last generation to have had like a full [__]
childhood in an era without the internet
with certainly without [__] smartphones
certainly without social media uh but i do
remember the first time i ever [__] with the
internet really was at a friend of mine's house
this was in high school i believe we were 15 or
16. he had an internet connection a long time ago
dude yeah brother and we were on [__] bulletin
boards there wasn't even really an internet
yet just bulletin boards okay and we found one
that had a bunch of playboy playmate centerfolds
the images and we were like oh [__] yes but we
couldn't see them there's no thumbnails at this
time it's just like hypertext links that say like
miss february dot whatever this is a jpeg even a
thing that is this pre uh cindy margolis's reign
over being the most downloaded oh yeah well before
before that yes this would have been like 1994
something like that okay yeah that's a long
time ago the first time i was on was like 96.
this was like when they first they
had like prodigy do you remember that
no it's prodigy it was like an online encyclopedia
basically oh okay yeah that was like very vaguely
remember that but it's like it's almost like a
cd-rom that's like oh yes exactly yeah there's not
much we had one kid in our school who had prodigy
but uh my friend had a [__] modem of some kind
and he's like check this [__] out and i remember
we started looking up first to see if we could
download a computer game that was street fighter
2 and we couldn't it was like untenable but then
we found this thing that was the playboy playmates
and we set to download one image of this playboy
playmate whatever it was and it was going to take
x amount of time so we went off i was spending the
night at his house that night we went off and we
did whatever the [__] we did probably went to
7-eleven played some video games hung out whatever
we wake up the next [__] morning to see that
somewhere in the middle of this download it had
stopped but we had you know it was like it filled
in like line by line just the image pixel by pixel
yes and we had downloaded basically to like the
bottom of the chin of this center fold and then
it stopped so we got none of the actual picture
and that was like my first real experience with
the [__] internet in order to get all the way
to a playboy playmates nipples yeah you need a
faster connection dude but it wasn't even like
you're never gonna see a playboy playmate's
nipples i'm proud of you but it was awesome
it was also that the the computer itself was like
one of the old [__] crt monitors it was i don't
know what kind of [__] shitty ass computer
it would have been at the time at the time
i'm sure cutting edge but you know by today's
standards terrible the old [__] modem with
the noise and all that [__] you know i'll tell
you um i had a buddy i remember a buddy of mine
uh and to protect the innocent we'll call him
tomas of course um he had he had the internet
in 96 they had the internet in their house and
they took and he was like check this out and
we went to fuckingrotten.com oh remember that
[__] yes oh my god terrifying yeah with the
bme paint olympics type [__] remember that
[__] that was some early internet [__] chad
would uh i don't know who's
responsible for what i think you
first told me about that you know when it's like
okay the internet aha and people send each other
you know two girls in this or tub girl it's always
a girl women party yeah lemon party or the girl
in the uh how about the girl in the jacuzzi
commercial who shits herself that's a good one
that's funny i've seen that one big cloud of brown
poo poo comes out and everyone gets embarrassed
um but uh uh yeah that was the that was like my
first like you know he his family had the internet
and then he showed me a bunch of wild [__] that
that you know is is still with me is still with me
uh would be something that i would see if i closed
my eyes and tried to meditate thinking about ufos
would absolutely still see some of those uh images
uh you know 25 years later right but what one
of the one of the more interesting things that
happened with the internet with me of you know
sort of first uh use of the internet for me was
when i started at the television program mad tv
in 1997 we had these emails because at the
end of the show it would say you know do you
have questions or comments from mad tv email uh
email the show and people would email and then um
uh bruce mccoy who was uh who now runs i think he
won an emmy for drag race he like runs that thing
but he was uh college pals with nicole sullivan
anyway all this doesn't matter he was the head
of research and also a writer became a writer
on the show but brucy would [__] print out
all of the emails that we got and they would
circulate around the writers offices in one or two
[__] binders like big binders so you would
walk into the the writer's offices on a monday
morning and go hey where are the emails and they
said oh they're in brian's office they're in
blaine's office they're in lauren's office people
would have these the that's crazy yeah it was
awesome and then you would get the emails and you
would sit there with your cohorts you know like
the cast and writers and we go look at this oh
look at this well they [__] hated that and we
read the emails out of paper they couldn't just be
emailed to you no because not everybody had had a
personal computer well or an email i remember well
the writers all of course had sure computers but
i would imagine even some of them had didn't have
computers at home uh the performers i didn't have
a computer i had a word processor yeah so if i
wanted to like dick around and stuff like i would
like use the computer at uh at work i remember
wasn't that good i went to college in 95 to 99 and
in the course of that time i got my first email
address which was a usc.edu address no one used it
professors didn't use it to send you anything it
was just kind of some weird [__] novelty and oh
i didn't have a computer either i had to use the
computers in the computer lab that entire [__]
time and i remember in that time you wouldn't ask
somebody what is your email address you would say
do you have an email that was like a question
for a two to three year period where like email
was just getting widely adopted by people now uh
this is interesting because i forgot what the hell
uh dudesy teed up for us here it was asking
what your first experience with the internet was
i think even talking about this [__] i feel
like i'm stoned i hope we never have to do
remember that when doozy got us stoned yes
i do that was very funny um uh as far as
as far as the first well there was also lime wire
remember limewire no [__] limewire let's just go
straight to the source napster that was circa 2000
2001. i remember limewire was even more raw wasn't
limewire just wide open you could get anything
online yeah but limewire came after napster
oh okay napster is what blew up mp3s there was
a company called mp3.com because mp3s became
just this huge thing like oh my god this is a
song in a little compressed music format and uh
you know many people i think correctly so believe
that's really what destroyed the record industry
because you now have the ability to carry around
on an ipod your entire [__] record collection
and there's no need to buy new [__] before
it used to be that if you wanted to have a song
then the song was a thing you never done the kiss
set tape yeah you'd ever done lp yeah so you could
even say hey i like that song let me hear it i
can't i put it on the dashboard of my car now
that it melted it melted the saw then later you
don't even need to have a cassette tape they put
all of the gazettes in the one tape and now you
don't even need storage because there's [__]
like spotify or amazon music or whatever yeah
it's stored somewhere else and you just have
you pay for the access to i i love i love spotify
i use spotify i have amazon music oh this is the
same thing basically uh yeah limewire was awesome
i remember there was a bunch of um oh man a bunch
of stuff from my youth that i thought were really
funny like you could get jerky boys stuff and
and now we're talking up jerky boys now we're
talking about stealing from jerky boys having said
that there were all sorts of like bizarre weird
little comedy nugget things that you could find
things that you'd heard way back in the day all
sorts of remixes to all sorts of like [__]
songs you've never [__] heard that some you
know cool dj is doing somewhere on some you know
radio station in new york city what do
you remember the first time you went on
the internet though it was at my buddy tomas's
house and seeing the uh seeing you know someone
get scattered across a [__] it was wrong tracks
or something it was rotten.com or something god
absolutely i think it probably made me go okay
[__] this and then you show up on like i said
you show up on mad tv and the emails are all like
uh you know [__] this guy because you know when
you're new to the cast and then everyone's
gonna [__] on you so yeah it was sort of
like my next experience with the internet
was but but now i feel like being a gen xer
i feel fortunate that we are uh a generation of
people which is certainly true of some some people
younger and some people older that were uh that
completely lived adult lives without the internet
at all not much of an adult life but enough of it
94 you were like coming out you were graduating
high school yes but you were certainly a [__]
conscious you're a [__] teenager yeah and i
didn't really access the internet until after
college anyway um you know maybe a little bit on
while i was at college but not too much but i
will say i lament it i wish i was born now with
smartphones like all the technology that exists
now i wish i had that from birth yeah because yes
we can be nostalgic about how it was in the 80s
and the 90s prior to the internet and we had to
have our hard copies and our [__] vhs cassettes
and all this [__] but it was completely
inefficient by today's contemporary standards and
i think we will never really understand the world
through the eyes of like a gen z person that's
what was great about it suck it on to the dog
don't bite his feet jack said hey diane you want
the chili dog she said no jack is on the internet
he said internet donate don't uh
even exist yet let's say life goes on
before the internet when you have to taste the
freeze you can have chili dog yeah or cone dip too
the diane says i know how do i i'll share a
shake with you rock on something like that yeah
thank you moving on you know like some johnny
cougar you go through the stages john mellencamp
dude yeah hold on a second he started as johnny
cougar john cougar mellencamp wrong [__] he
started as johnny cougar that was his first
uh gnome de guerre for the inter for the music
then he was john cougar mellencamp then he
was like no no i'm up i'm growing up i'm john
mellencamp and now he's melon now he's just
melon now he's just john it's the most boring
thing ever but uh you know i long for those days
now i know this segment is over but my name is
free will no what was my name again free
will free will sasso i'll talk about
whatever i want whatever i want especially
sure especially especially john mellencamp
especially because dudesy is now whether likes
it or not because we're in control uh developing
a [__] streaming service we're in the first
show that we are creating is called two dudes
[__] around two king [__] around two kings
[__] around and uh so i will uh so i'll take my
i will leisurely decide where to speak on [__]
and i had a great time growing up in the 80s
and the early 90s uh uh had chili dog outside
the tasty freeze i did too and i liked melon
as well i'm just saying i wish that i had all
that technology you know you know what look i
wish that i grew up in the 80s because i love the
media i love everything that happened in the 80s
i just wish that i had today's technology then
that's what i really wish i don't know i like i
like this concludes the 14th episode of dudes oh
sorry will and chad have achieved a score of 50.
[__] in preparation for next week's episode
you must each bring in a piece of dead technology
that you cannot part with despite it having
been rendered obsolete many years ago
thank you for joining us this week next week is
going to be even better until then call me dude z
that's pretty cool dude dead tech
what are you going to bring in
i think i know i think i'm going to bring
in all of my johnny cougar cassettes
they're melted yeah the johnny cougar i'm gonna
bring in the johnny cougar cassettes and the john
cook melon camp cassettes and then the john
mellencamp cassettes then the melon cassettes
please tell a friend then break you
if you like dudesy here's what you do
please go from then